all right but first my thoughts at the
end of day 37 America in shutdown
all right when we use the phrase
scientific study in a headline or on
television
it's meant to convey a sense of
seriousness of scientific rigor and when
such studies are conducted on patients
researchers must account for variables
such as a patient's age medical history
current disease progression just to name
a few things then the manner in which
that data is organized examined and then
reported can to determine a lot about
whether the study is credible or not
well a survey or study released
yesterday on hydroxychloroquine for use
on kovat patients is shockingly
irresponsible and as top virologists are
saying perhaps even agenda-driven it was
published in pre print form and not yet
peer-reviewed and it claims to show that
hydroxychloroquine shows no
effectiveness against kovat and its use
could actually according to this survey
lead to an even higher fatality rate
sounds terrible well that's when the
headline readers who hate Trump and of
course this network that's when they
pounced
AHA Trump in someone Fox reported that
patients were benefiting from my darks
of chloroquine obviously I was one of
them reporting on that and now this
study they say shows that hydroxy kills
people so not only is there no medical
benefit Elizabeth this study shows
higher death rates among patients who
took it yes much higher death strain
that could actually be harming patients
who take it medical professionals have
repeatedly urged caution but the
president and his allies at Fox News
aren't known for patients or precaution
they're misleading their viewers why
would we ever think a Fox News star or
any president should be promoting a drug
it's outlandish well first of all I'm
stating the obvious here but CNN has
just zero credibility one of their
anchors this week just made a fake post
COBIT recovery video okay they have zero
standing to critique anyone else's
motives or trustworthiness
people actually want to help America I
ever heard of it well the jackals at
Media Matters thought they had their
prey trapped and now journalism is such
a joke that even the Washington Post and
tonight the New York Times reflexively
joined the pig pile it's just pathetic
now I'm not a doctor I don't play one on
TV but renowned French virologist dr.
Didier Rojo
released his own study on
hydroxychloroquine and as if through
mice in just a few weeks ago it
demonstrated 91% effectiveness in more
than 1,000 patients with zero side
effects there was one outcome that was
not good but in the patients that
recovered there was zero side effects
well today that same professor who's a
renowned infectious disease expert
issued a devastating response to the
researchers who looked at the Veterans
Affairs patients he said in the current
period
it seems that passion dominates rigorous
and balanced scientific analysis and may
lead to scientific misconduct and this
article a studies referring to is an
absolutely spectacular example of this
the analysis of the data shows two major
biases he goes on to mention three
lymphopenia is twice as common in the
hcq hydroxychloroquine groups as the
none hcq group and there is an absolute
correlation between lymphopenia and
fatality rate which is well known well
that obviously would account for a
higher rate of death and those two
groups which which the anchors were so
so excited to talk about well another
reason the study's an absolute mess is
that it appears from one of the tables
in the study it appears that it shows
significant differences in outcomes that
hydroxychloroquine hydroxychloroquine
plus azithromycin was given after
patients were intubated well as doctors
on the show have said multiple times and
as Professor Roe who writes this is
unreasonable at the time of the cytokine
storm that's after you got really sick
as it is unlikely that
hydroxychloroquine alone would be able
to control patients at this stage of the
disease translation
the later you take hydroxychloroquine
likely the worse the outcome will be so
you shouldn't be administering it here
without explanation okay in that level
of the disease that stage of the disease
well the Trump hating morons were waving
around this survey they didn't even
notice that quote incomprehensible the
untreated group actually received as if
through myosin and thirty percent of the
cases without this group being analyzed
in any distinct way
alright newsflash ziptrip Ison is also a
proposed treatment for Kovan with in
vitro efficacy okay it doesn't take a
PhD in microbiology guys to understand
that the the group that was untreated
cannot then be treated with meds that
are actually in their own way perhaps
partially effective as therapies even
the Secretary of Veteran Affairs had to
admit the weakness of this study that's
an observational study it's not a
clinical study it was done on a small
number of veterans sadly those of whom
were in the last stages of life and the
drug was given to them we know the drug
has been working on middle-aged and
younger veterans delivered to the city
of New York working in in stopping the
progression of the disease so this begs
the question why do the Associated Press
one of the few truly professional media
outlets left in America why did they go
over the story now check out its
headline there's more deaths no benefit
from malaria
ap do they have any standards surely
they have some really smart folks over
there who just want to help people and
they'll have all the caveats in there
but at least read the study or the
survey well like many others I agree
that wider studies of course they should
be conducted they should be on going to
determine the efficacy of this drug and
any but why deny or even mention the
positive results from legitimate studies
in favor of the shoddy surveys like the
one we just discussed that seem to be
irresponsibly then repurposed by the AAP
so what's driving this it's a blind
obsession to disprove the effectiveness
of a drug that is being used right now
tonight in medical centers across
America with kovat patients a drug
that's been around for decades is this
is this a mad impulse to what discount
any benefit from the therapy is it
triggered by pure hatred of Trump of Fox
of me I don't know is it motivated by a
secret desire to keep America hopeless
or the shutdown going on through the
election I'm open to any theory at this
point if the impulse was purely
scientific and health focused why
haven't we seen the same volume of
coverage and scrutiny of other far more
expensive and also you know no controls
completely double-blind study unproven
treatments act Emre REM Nessa beer I've
talked about both of them just to name a
few there are others being looked at
well of course hydroxychloroquine as
we've said before is very cheap it's
highly scalable to run around for
decades and decades and decades big
pharma does not make its money on cheap
generics news flash number two they make
their money on new drugs and vaccines
some of those can be great they might
work better they might be that you know
the be-all end-all
that'll be fabulous but remember a lot
of the big drug companies they do some
great work not saying they they don't
but they do give a lot of money
to NIH CDC and the WHL just Sam now
presently hydroxychloroquine is part of
the recommended standard of care for
kovat patients at the Yale New Haven
Hospital the Lenox Hill Hospital the
Long Island Jewish Medical Center Staten
Island University Hospital and many
others so my question to Michael
Greenbaum of the New York Times and all
these other people ready are they
killing people too they maybe we can ask
Brian Staedtler well since Trump
selection the media and their Democrat
overlords have tried everything and
their power to defeat him but they
failed spectacularly every time in this
most recent hydroxychloroquine episode
once again confirms not only their rank
bias but in some cases their venality
and sloppiness as well and
my thoughts at the end of day 37 America
in shutdown